thank you so much dotty for that thought
provoking and lovely introduction giving
a talk about my book at an esteemed
institution like Harvard is quite a
change for me from my usual daily fare
of negotiating with five and
six-year-olds the environment that I
teach in is a privileged one in terms
both of the latitude that I'm allowed to
create my own curriculum and in terms of
the class size which is small enough for
me to really get to know every child in
the room and it provided me with a
unique opportunity to listen and to
reflect that led to this book today I
want to tell you about a time when I
felt discouraged and the important part
that the children played in helping me
understand what was happening in my own
classroom as well as in my own feelings
this understanding enabled me to
rediscover my own role in teaching these
children I had been teaching young
children for over 20 years I'd counseled
the most emotionally disturbed children
with Bruno Bettelheim I've been the
director of a nursery school I taught
kindergarten with Vivian Paley but the
first time I heard the children in my
classroom talk about the suicide game
dead man and blood man I felt like a
beginning teacher all over again
what I thought I knew about teaching was
not working for this group of five and
six-year-olds I knew I needed to take a
fresh look at violence in children's
play and find new ways to teach and
understand the children that were in my
care my first introduction to Deadman
and blood man came through my tape
recorder I had decided that I might
write about ways to connect young
children's play with their early reading
experience and I thought I might begin
by making reading books that were based
on their fantasy play when I first began
to transcribe my tapes of their play
this is what I heard anybody knows he's
dead right I heard CEFs six-year-old
voice he goes over a lumpy force field
I've seen part two of it parts who is
awesome a dead man says give me that
money the guy says all right but head
and the other one says who are you
calling that and he says oh oh and he
sticks out his hand and he grabs his
heart and he rips it out Daniel answers
more softly yeah but ghosts don't have
hearts Seth doesn't miss a beat as he
continues his narrative yeah but dead
man did that to another guy no it's
under dead man's skin no it's under his
skin its bones and blood he's got
people's everything Daniel have you seen
the movie dead man no Daniel admits good
stuff continues its gory and it's rated
R right you can't even see rated ours
can you can you see rated ours Kayla you
don't even want to see rated r you don't
want to see dead man it's totally Gore e
right I know why it's rated R Kayla says
he ripped off a hand who cares she adds
kayla has two big brothers and she knows
how to talk to boys no he didn't Seth
tells her you never seen dead man but
Kayla holds her ground yeah I heard you
guys talking about it yeah Seth answers
but that was a part I made up right
Daniel all it is is
murderer says I'll kill you I'll kill
you I'll kill you you don't want to see
dead man it's just talking yeah Daniel
agrees it only has a few violence in it
like two or three I decided right then
that I would not use their fantasy play
for early reading books I wanted to
avoid listening to it or thinking about
what these boys had said but instead I
found I was haunted by their voices I
had several questions why did the
children love these very images of
explicit violence that I so strongly
hated what could I is their teacher do
to help them put aside this
preoccupation they had so they could
concentrate on other activities telling
the children to stop their fantasies was
ineffective worse yet I saw they would
either play their games where I could
not hear them or when I asked about
their games they tried to convince me
their imaginary guns were only fire
hoses I seem to be teaching them to be
deceitful the main purpose of my writing
was for myself writing about a problem
forces me to clarify my thoughts I also
know that audio tapes of the play and
discussions in my classroom are a good
way for me to learn more about what's
going on and to help me be a more
effective teacher when I began to write
I had not heard other teachers talk
about this problem this was before the
school shootings and children's violence
had hit the news yet I guess that I was
probably not the only teacher struggling
with these issues and as I began to talk
with other teachers I discovered that
many shared my concerns about the
problem I decided I would work in three
ways the first would consist of
discussions with the children in my
class the second would be conversations
with older children who I hoped would be
better able to explain to me why they
loved violence the third would be to
understand why i hated
so much with the hope that this would
allow me to be more empathic with the
children in my class I began a series of
discussions with a five and
six-year-olds about their play I hoped
we would learn what kinds of play made
them upset when they came in from recess
unsettled argumentative and unable to
listen to others or focus on a group
task I wanted to look for ways that I
could help them establish rules for
their recess games they would enable
them to have satisfying play but be able
to come inside calm and ready to learn I
expected that I would find that when
they played about the most explicitly
gory violent fantasies they would come
in upset while if they played about more
peaceful fantasies they would come in
calm this theory turned out to be mostly
wrong gori content did upset some
children and we made rules to limit the
explicit violence in their play of
course I made rules to protect both the
physical and emotional safety of the
children but when I listen to what the
children told me i discovered that when
they agreed on the rules of a game when
no one was excluded and when the game
was not overly competitive they could
play games that had violent fantasy
content in a cooperative and peaceful
way violent fantasy content was not the
same as aggressive play for example they
played a game called the shooting game
one child pointed a finger and said bang
and the second player was supposed to
fall down and pretend to be dead instead
the second player would shout you missed
me and the first player would call back
you're cheating you know how it goes
from there we made rules for this game
the children decided the shooter had to
stay over an arm's length away from the
person being shot and the person who was
shot at had to fall down when the
shooter said I got you but that he could
get up after counting to ten once the
shooter knew that the person shot at
would fall
down without an argument and the person
shot knew he could get up and continue
playing after counting to 10 the game
became a cooperative and peaceful
version with no real anger or aggression
another surprise to me was the
connection that I found between real
violence and exclusion as I began to
transcribe my audio tapes of our
discussions and of the interviews with
the older children I found I was often
writing about exclusion I decided to put
those discussions aside for a different
project because I wanted to stick to the
subject of violence but after a while I
realized that the issue of exclusion
insisted on coming in and that I needed
to find out why what I saw was there
seem to be two ways violence and
exclusion were linked first the child
who felt excluded was so hurt he seemed
to feel justified in using violence
toward those who had caused him pain the
second and more startling to me was that
after a group had excluded a child by
calling him a name like Mama's little
baby or calling a boy a girl or [ __ ]
the excluding children seemed to feel
justified in acting violently toward
that other child for no other reason
than that he was no longer considered
one of them
my interviews with older children helped
me to understand some of the reasons why
my young children might be so fascinated
by the very violence that I found
repulsive one of these a ten-year-old
boy i called jason said that he had been
obsessed with violence since he was five
and had discovered Batman at the same
time he was clearly a very caring boy
who could look at both sides of many
situations I told him that when I watch
violent images I identify so strongly
with the person receiving the violence
that I can't watch it and I wondered how
he felt when he watched it here's what
he told me it's sort of like you must
get trained he said it's like in the
military when they saw that not very
many people were shooting their guns
they started training them to think that
it was okay to shoot you know and like
when you play a violent game you play it
enough you almost start getting trained
to kill and not thinking about who
you're killing he loved violent video
games particularly I think that's what
happens as a kid sees enough violent
stuff he doesn't think about the pain
that the other person would go through
he thinks about the good things like the
bad guys dead partly it's like if you
think about it enough it starts not
being scary anymore like I saw this
movie at my friend's house and I thought
it was really very scary and I went over
to his house again and we saw it again
and it wasn't that scary that time but
it was still pretty scary and we watched
it again and again and little by little
it started getting less scary until it
wasn't scary at all it's like the same
thing with fear he continued I remember
when I was a little kid I used to be
afraid to put my head out of the
blankets at night and then eventually
over the years I got less and less
afraid and I would peek out sometimes
and then when I got to be like nine
years old I would go to sleep with my
head out as long as I kept my eyes
and when I got to be 10 I could lie in
bed with my eyes open and then I went
over to my friends house and we saw this
really scary movie and it sort of
brought the whole thing back it sort of
like hit the reset button I get these
images in my head at night like I'd
stick my head out and I imagine like a
disgusting image like popping up from
like over the side of my bed and it's
really scary something from The Exorcist
that's what the movie was and when my
friend told me about a movie where
someone has the power to make people
stab themselves with pitchforks well
before I had seen the Exorcist that
wouldn't have been really scary to me
but it adds on it builds up I think it's
the same thing with violence once you
get used to it it's really hard to reset
the button unless you experience
something really violent seeing violent
movies as a way to master fierce was a
new and surprising idea to me and when I
could understand it felt a little like
the way I had discovered I could face my
anxieties about the children's
fascination with violence by letting
myself look at it more carefully the
third part of my book dealt with my
increasing understanding of my antipathy
toward violence I had learned in my work
with Bettelheim that if I wanted to
understand someone who seemed very
different from myself I first had to
understand my own feelings I could see
that the intensity of my dislike of
violence made it hard for me to be
empathic with the boys in my class who
loved it as I began to understand that
the intensity of my antipathy for
violence was rooted in my identification
with the great aunt I was named for who
had died in a concentration camp I began
to accept that having fantasies
containing some violent content is
normal for children and that they can
have these fantasies without becoming
killers
young children however not able
consistently to know the difference
between fantasy and reality several
older children told me that when they
were younger imagining they were a
character from a movie or from
television had led them to do something
they otherwise would have known was
dangerous one boy for instance was
pretending to be Kevin in home alone he
was standing at the top of a long marble
staircase in a hotel and he heard his
father's footsteps coming up the stairs
he decided that his father was a robber
and this boy slid down the long banister
and fell off fortunately his mother was
standing at the bottom and caught him he
told me that he knew afterward that it
was dangerous but at that moment he was
Kevin I decided it was important that
these young children not be exposed to
the very violent images they were saying
they saw on television and in the movies
I sent a letter home to their parents
asking them to be more aware of what
their children were seeing and to limit
it appropriately this letter got more
positive feedback from parents than any
parent letter I've ever sent home
mothers especially welcomed the support
for this stand that would come from
taking it together as a group so their
child would not see a movie at another
child's house that they were prohibited
from seeing at home it also helped them
answer the usual complaint that everyone
else can see it that inevitably occurs
when a parent says no as I became less
afraid to hear about their games as I
saw the children were able to make their
own rules about their play that helped
them to be more cooperative I became
more confident in the group process that
we were evolving together I continued to
set the rules for physical and emotional
safety rules like no touching when you
pretend to fight and you can't say you
can't play from Vivian Paley's book by
that name but I found that the more I
allowed the children to formulate their
own rules the more they were learning to
listen to each other to see issues from
more than one viewpoint and to make
compromises that satisfied the needs of
each member of the group in the
beginning it was difficult for me to
trust this process of allowing the
children to formulate their own rules
even though I was setting the rules that
I thought most important I was afraid
the children's rules might not be good
enough as I saw how much they learned
from this constructivist process and I
realized that if their rules did not
work out well we could go back and
revise them I came to increasingly value
our new process a critical moment in
this change came after some parents
complained to me that their children had
told them the recess play was too
violent I decided to talk with the
children about the problem and I'm going
to read you a piece of a longer chapter
in the book called the rules of violence
when I tell the children what the
parents had said Gregory speaks
immediately I know he says I told my mom
because I didn't like the game where
people took eyeballs out I'm relieved
that Gregory spoke up first if Seth had
begun with a defense of violence it
might have been hard for the others to
admit their feelings but Gregory is a
leader a frequent team captain in soccer
once they've heard him speak most of the
children will feel they can speak
honestly when we play Super Mario
Brothers Travis says the princess is
turned to guck I don't like that I think
taking eyeballs out and slimer both
gross Alison agrees and I don't like it
when people chop you in half and get you
all bloody I'm startled by her the image
that her pronoun implies I did not
imagine one of the children being
chopped and bloodied I had pictured only
an invisible enemy
but that's probably everything was in
violent stories self complaints no I
tell him you can still have good guys
and bad guys getting killed without
chopping them up and having them get all
bloody Nina speaks for the first time I
don't think people should say I'm going
to chop you up in my story if you don't
do this part she explains threats are
another aspect of the game I had not
thought about I'm glad to have Nina on
my side nothing's too gross for me SEF
boasts taking off your socks and
smelling them Gregory says that's too
gross I don't want people to take a
sword and stick it through someone's
tummy and bones fallout caffee ads
Gregory looks at the growing list I've
been writing on the board as the
children talk erase the socks he tells
me i want the socks these gross and
scary things off it into the rules we
made earlier in the year i point out the
rules about violence in the stories you
tell me i wrote those rules rules down
to no excessive blood no chopping off of
body parts no guts or other things that
are inside the body can come out we
could use the same rules out at recess
that we use for our storytelling in the
classroom I explained but that's
probably half the stuff that's in
violence Seth protests again how about
us that's no fair children have to be in
school I tell him they need a safe place
where they don't feel grossed out if
your parents let you you can play what
you want to at your own house fine Seth
answers to finally I'll do it at my
house all day with no one to tell me to
stop why can't we do it at recess Nina
suggests where if anybody says I don't
like that we just moved to a different
place where people don't mind Gregory
adds to her proposal one recess we play
no violence and the next one we play
violence
I feel discouraged to see our near
agreement slipping away but Nina
explains the rule that she and Gregory
are developing that way she says the
people who don't like violence but they
do want to play with the people who like
gross stuff can play with them at the
next recess this seems so reasonable I
find it hard to disagree VOA TVO 80 Erin
spells let's vote he he has recently
learned that when two vowels go walking
the first one does the talking I
summarize the new proposal children can
play games involving violent language at
alternate recesses so the children who
do not like violence have a chance to
play with their friends who do like it
if anyone objects to the violence the
players must find a new location of
course there's never any really real
hitting or pushing in the game when they
pretend to fight they can never touch
one another the children adopt the new
rule I feel as though I've lost maybe I
should have made the rule myself we came
so close to a nearly unanimous banning
of most explicit verbal violence at
recess before Nina and Gregory turned
the tide against it why did they do that
when they so courageously spoke out
against the excessive violence at the
beginning of the discussion surely they
are not afraid of seth's anger I've seen
them disagree with him publicly many
times could it be that they want to
protect children from hearing the
violence they don't like but they also
want Seth to be allowed to play the
games that he loves their recess rules
have ingeniously protected everyone in a
complex agreement I would never have
imagined they require the children
playing together to listen to each other
to respect one another's needs and to be
inclusive exactly the values I've
stressed all year my respect for the
children and for the group process goes
up the more I think about what has taken
place we have an agreement that's better
than any rule I could have imposed as
the year went on the children were able
to come to agreements by consensus with
increasing independence so that
eventually they could even at times
solve problems at recess and come in and
report to me when they came inside many
authors write a book to tell others
about an idea that the author has
already decided is true I think of
myself first and foremost as a teacher I
wrote under dead man's skin about what I
did not know and about what at first I
would have preferred to avoid in the
process of understanding why these
children loved violence and what I as
their teacher could do about it I
discovered that their violent play
actually had an important purpose and
that any plan for dealing with it had to
take that meaning into account by
listening carefully to the children
especially when it seemed most difficult
to do so I could like Jason keep my head
out of the covers and my eyes open
um my name is sherikov allen freshman at
harvard and i was wondering whether you
found a difference between the way the
boys and the girls in your class dealt
with the violence and also whether the
older kids who talk to ever had any
regrets about how they'd played i don't
know where they students in your class
if they'd had regrets about how they'd
played before or reactions to that and
if they felt they changed since then
there were differences between the boys
and the girls in this class in their
reactions to violence it was
predominantly boys who were playing
those violent games although not
exclusively Nina was enjoying them also
but one difference between them was that
the girls in this group were more likely
to want to think about what the meaning
of what was happening might be for
instance a girl would sit at the lunch
table watching some boys talk about
their popsicle stick battleship and say
why do boys like violence so much so
that was one difference the girls had a
much quieter way in this group of being
involved in violence they would leave
someone out quietly and for instance one
girl would compliment everyone in her
circle around her except one girl and
they all knew she was going to leave out
that girl they were waiting for her to
do it and then she would look up and see
me watching and see she'd say oh and I
like your hair band so as one older girl
told me boys tease girls spread rumors
would you repeat the second part again
the second part was you did it part of
your research was talking to older
students who were able to explain the
violence more and I was wondering what
their reactions if they ever had
reactions to how they had played when
they were younger or how they still
played whether they're like yeah we
still do it and we shouldn't that we do
it anyway because it's fun or or
reactions like that it's a funny thing I
had a discussion a couple days ago with
one of the children who played the
suicide game he happened to not be
feeling well and he was sitting in the
office waiting to be picked up and he
said to me you know my dad's reading
your book and I said oh and he said
what's it about exactly and I said well
you know that play that teachers don't
usually like that much it's about that
kind of play and he said you know I used
to play that suicide game he said what
if children don't stop it and I said
well what do you think and he said I
think most of the time they just outgrow
it
one of the children that one of the
older children Jason that I interviewed
I talked to him after the Columbine
shootings because the interview I read
was before that and I asked him if he
had changed his mind at all or had any
new ideas about his love of violent
video games because that was such an
issue in the media coverage of that
event and he at that point said that he
had begun to rethink the issue and that
he thought that violent video games were
a problem sometimes not necessarily for
people for children who weren't worried
about things but for children who had
built up anger inside that he thought it
could really be bad for them and I asked
him what he thought his parents should
do because he valued his parents
opinions even when he disagreed with
them and he said that he thought that
maybe they shouldn't let him play them
so much was reading your book I was
struck by how sort of purposeful so much
what you did in your classroom was you
really did take a lot of time to talk
with the children and evaluate things
negotiate but I think your experience in
a classroom maybe a little foreign to
some teachers whose classrooms are
really quite chaotic and I'm wondering
if you've been able to figure out how
you would advise teachers to sort of
bring about a more peaceable kingdom
within their classrooms and also I'd
love to know how your observations how
you translated those to the other
teachers that you work with and what
that discussion was like and how it's
influenced your school if at all
I am lucky to have so much ability to
plan my own curriculum and to actually
make this a part of my curriculum in
terms of helping the children learn how
to deal more cooperatively with each
other and I think that one way that I
came to look at how to do that was if
you if you as a teacher can take the
issues that are troublesome in terms of
violent play and divide them into three
categories the first category would be
issues that have to do with safety
either physical safety or emotional
safety and make rules to protect the
children around those things I make
those rules those are not up for
negotiation and as I described one one
of my rules for physical safety is no
touching when you pretend to fight as
long as the children are following that
rule I don't have to worry that they're
actually going to hurt each other but in
a rule for emotional safety that I
consider just as important as you can't
say you can't play because exclusion is
an issue that tends to result in real
anger in real conflict so that's the
first kind of issue that comes up
another kind of issue that comes up is
kinds of play that I might not
personally enjoy but they're not causing
a problem in my classroom for instance
this year Pokemon is big in my room and
although i don't like pokemon play its
linguistically uninteresting it the
children don't talk to each other very
much they make noises that other people
who don't watch the movie can't
understand so I don't think it's as
valuable as some kinds of fantasy play
but I don't have a problem with it
because when Pokemon players
do their aggressive acts toward each
other they happen over space like
somebody says and then something happens
to somebody across the way and then
whoever is stronger winds a metal it's
actually not very bloody and so the
combination with being not physically
aggressive makes it tolerable to me even
though it's not as favorite as mine as
say the year we had Peter Pan with all
the wonderful pirate ships being built
in the black area so there are some
things that I just decide to let go
because they don't bother me that much
they're not really causing conflict the
issues that come up in between those two
areas are the ones that the children can
really learn from and grow from and have
discussions about so that for instance
the shooting game where there were
conflicts that were really upsetting the
children was a good place to start with
letting them make rules for themselves
if the rule didn't work then we'd hear
about it because the conflicts would
continue and we could make some
different rules the next day so that
that's how I decide what stand to take
with any particular conflicts that come
up
i'm jealous burger i teach a course
called violence and non-violence in
theory and fiction here so i'm very
intrigued by what you're saying my
students do a lot of work with story
short stories and I guess what I'm
wondering about is the whole issue of
punishment and silencing or subdue until
dhryn or even people who are older so
that when you talked about how when you
have exclusion going on first of all the
child who excludes others you said felt
justified and that also the excluded kid
felt so hurt let me rephrase that so
that he or she felt entitled to use
greater violence as a sort of way of
getting back but also the those who
exclude felt more entitled to increase
the ante and so I was thinking about the
nature of punishment of what happens
when a child does something wrong or an
older person does something wrong and
people remove them they basically
exclude them and they attempt to subdue
them so that they begin a way the child
or the older person becomes more
silenced more subdued more detached
which would seem to be more dangerous as
an expression as a potential site of
violence because we would have no
reading on the feelings because we're so
I'm wondering how you go about
influencing notions of punishment then
in your school or advising others well
in my class I'm talking about very young
children and I think that most of the
time they don't know they don't really
understand the effect that they're
having on each other and they don't know
how to get the effect that they want and
so I think it's much more valuable to
them to be a part of a group that's
exploring those issues than to be
separated from it now there certainly
might be times that you need to separate
a child for some reason but I think that
in general a lot more growth of
understanding is going
happen if they're a part of a group
that's exploring what the effects are of
what they are doing and what they might
do differently in order to get an effect
that's really what they want violence
how would you translate that
because out of your class or into a
school setting or into a cultural
setting of some sort is it possible
I really have to stick to the age group
that I'm used to working with although I
did read a very interesting book called
called violence um pardon yes by James
Gilligan that does address that subject
in a really unusual in thought-provoking
way
yes thank you by the way for coming this
evening and opening the opportunity for
teachers to come and visit and listen to
what you have to say I am an elementary
education teacher in Lexington and I
find it very interesting that although I
do keep abreast of a lot of information
that goes across the curriculum and I've
been reading a lot about play with in PE
class and how they're stopping games of
bombardment or kickball because it's too
gets a lot of competition and children
are still left out and yet hour before
school extensions allow that to take
place as far as kickball know the games
and those are actually facilitated by
the PE teacher and then the after-school
clubs of course have the same games
going on at that time so all the the
evidence of violence and left out and
the personal persecution which which two
of them do feel is obviously quite
evident and and consistent with what
you're saying so it came about that
about two weeks ago the fifth graders
want to challenge the teachers and it
gave a kickball and of course I did that
when I was in elementary school and the
fifth graders always looked forward
towards that at the end of the year we
get to play teachers and of course we
always lost its fifth graders but it was
fun to get to play him and oh I see the
old rickety teachers out there who you
didn't think could even kick a ball no
less walk the principal said no no we
don't believe in competition in that
respect so we have more interactive
games and we have a big swimming pool
party yet he seems to be I was wondering
what the irony was or how it's the
mountain misconception about why then
that sort of play is allowed in PE how
you feel about that and how that has a
great bearing upon what happens in a
classroom
I certainly think that with the age of
children that I work with the
competitive games are really difficult
for them even when they're old enough to
understand the rules and they seem to be
able to play by the rules they still
find it very difficult to lose and take
it very personally I had a group a few
years ago who were spectacular chess
players at five unbelievably good but
when they lost they throw the board
across the room and I had to ban chess
from the class for that year so even
though they look as though they can
handle it a lot of times they take it so
personally they really can't do it
two things when you are starting the
questions about the answer and the
questions you brought up the thing about
the girls playing those little mind
games that they do with the other girls
to make them feel a little you seem to
be equated that with the roughhousing
and the physical throwing in the gross
behavior which I found hard to see what
the connection was between the two of
them you seem to be making something
about it exclusion or inclusion or
something but yet you were maintaining
this violent plague within the classroom
but banning the inclusion so seems to me
that the roughhousing doesn't depend
upon inclusion or exclusion that you can
still have violent play without
inclusive sort of activities exclusive
sort of activities going on it was one
thing the other thing was I wonder what
would have happened if you'd let some of
this the exclusive sort of behavior just
continue with the kids and see what how
it would have panned out how with and
maybe the kids would have for a time
acted as if they were an excluded
exclusionary little groups but then over
time they would have come back with all
their different multivariate interests
and the situation would equalize itself
again over time you know so that the big
the kids were going to end up being big
beefy army soldiers can carry on being
roughhousers they were the ones whether
the smart little kids can take interests
and other sorts of things and indeed
their power comes back in that respect
that certainly would be a different way
of approaching the problem but since is
very important to me that with these
young children each of them be empowered
to be able to feel competent in the
classroom socially and emotionally and
in terms of their work I really place an
emphasis on inclusion in the group so
because that's my philosophy
everything that I do in the classroom
builds on those issues in terms of the
girls and their exclusion my point was
that although boys are more physically
aggressive in their play the girls have
a type of aggression that comes out
verbally and can be just as hurtful as
the boys physical aggression or teasing
is it sometimes comes out it's hard to
compare the hurt from a physical wound
and from a verbal one but but certainly
both are very painful there's no even
though they might be using nasty words
at each other there's no real and
doesn't seem to me there's an you real
intent to hurt each other in the way
that you know excluding it to a girl
excluding another girlfriend that's
deliberately cruel you know right I
think that is quite they're really quite
different mm-hmm yeah I found two
different kinds of violence one is the
aggression that comes about through
physical contact which sometimes isn't
angry it can be a rough-and-tumble kind
of puppy play in young children and then
um and sometimes it is angry and then
there's also violence that is the
content of a person's fantasy life and
that can be played out physically
peacefully so the children can be
pretending to shoot each other and have
no physical aggression at all and my
point is that having violent fantasy
content is not necessarily dangerous if
it's being played in a cooperative way
and all the players are agreeing to the
rules
michael barr
I'm just wondering a clarification of
the space really like were they all
playing the same game or were there are
different games and were you only trying
to intervene in games that were
problematic are they caused problems
because I just remember when I was in
elementary school we had a huge space
and it was very little supervision and
we all just did whatever games were
mm-hmm um if we I mean there's so many
different playing so many different
games right that's true in my class too
there are many different groups and the
children who are talking about the blood
man and dead man was a small group in my
classroom while other children were
playing puppies and kitties in the black
area that certainly was true and I
certainly didn't intervene in play that
wasn't causing anybody a problem but
things have changed since you and I went
to school and now children in
kindergarten can be suspended for
pointing a finger and saying bang in
schools so there have been big societal
changes since that time and people are
much more concerned about the fantasy
content of what children are playing
student in pastoral ministry and I'm
working on a paper and violence and
spirituality and it occurs to me that
you could do this on an individual basis
and that's very effective but in a
setting like this of a graduate school
of education I wonder if in fact there
shouldn't be some attempt to make this
more of a part of a curriculum and you
know have this brought out either in a
case study way even as young as your
grade or may perhaps a little bit older
when children have had experience with
violent situations to reflect on cases
say how would you feel if you were Alice
in this situation or whatever and just
have people go through vicarious
experiences of their own feelings as
being the aggressor pond or the
aggressor and I'd like to hear what you
have to say about them thank you I think
that's a good idea we do a lot of that
in my classroom when a situation comes
up that's problematic will act out the
situation and children will I'll ask the
children for suggestions for how it
might be resolved and then the two
children who are acting out that problem
will decide how they're going to end
their story but I think one of the
values of it is that they see that in
any given situation there are a lot of
possible ways to deal with a problem and
that they can find one that feels right
to them and so is a group process as
well as in an individual process I think
it can be really helpful I guess I'm
making a pitch for this to be a little
bit more part of the educational system
because i think our schools as you said
are very different and we have different
you know we have different settings
people coming from different
environments they're much more exposed
to violent television video games etc so
I think we have to look at that
seriously and perhaps change you know
and make it a little more part of the
formal education so that's what I just
like that's why I wrote my book
I'm Carol surf and I'm chair of the
Cambridge Public Health Committee and we
consider violence one of our big issues
of public health issues one of my
concerns is when I had little boys and
this was before videos and TV they
played violent games a bang bang you're
dead and my passive his friends I
thought that was awful but I thought it
was working out their aggressions in a
harmless way and they all grow up to be
fine upstanding citizens and they don't
go around shooting people do you find
that some of this violent play is
actually useful I had cap guns too and I
played Annie Oakley hello fringe vest
and a cowgirl skirt and and I played the
same game with my brother and we're
we're both in the helping professions
now and and I agree with you I think
that it's very important for children to
be allowed to express their fantasies
for a lot of reasons I think that that
it's important for them to know that
having those fantasies doesn't mean that
they're bad that it's a normal part of
growing up and when they play those
games together they're discovering that
an adult who read my book said before I
read your book I thought I was the only
one who thought those things as a child
and she was relieved to find out that
wasn't true so I think there's a value
that way there's another value though in
that it's a window to see what our
children are thinking and feeling about
a teacher asked me whether it was
alright that she had not intervened when
two children were playing a game after
the Columbine shooting where one was
standing up and the other was pretending
to shoot her and then they would fall
down and laugh and get up and play it
again and it was clearly a reenactment
of what they had seen on the television
and
I think that not only is it important
that they be allowed to play that but
also it gives the adult a chance to
discuss it with them because children
can have many misconceptions and need
clarification from adults when they've
seen something that does disturb them so
it's an opportunity to do that and to
really listen to the children rather
than to silence their concerns I think
in a way I think of that as being as if
the day after the Columbine shootings
someone had walked into our staff room
at school and said anyone who thinks
about the Columbine shootings is going
to become a killer it wouldn't have been
helpful to us we needed to first of all
express our feeling for the people we
had seen and heard about what would it
have been like to be those people the
mothers the children the teachers and
then to plan what could we do could this
really happen here is there anything we
can do to make it better and what those
children are doing when they're playing
this game is exactly the same thing
they're experienced the empathy for what
those other people had gone through and
then they're wondering could it happen
to me and it's a chance for us to
explore that with them
Thank You Jane Jane will be around tiny
books after with words and you can bring
your individual questions tour of it
thanks so much